hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play abduction I got it oh I got
it it's backwards ba ck w ay RDS is just
two codes backwards because backwards
its backwards its backwards uh-huh so
smart I judge Martin I'm so smart I did
not look up anything on the Internet's I
figured that out all by myself oh yeah
yeah oh look at me oh I win I win oh the
best look at me
oh yeah oh so smart
look at my big brain ha no no no no no
get out of here get out of here who's
there ah I'm looking at you all right
wasn't I no get out of here can't find
me I'm under the stairs
Oh perfect hiding place get out of here
buddy
don't even try it
I'm Way too tough and smart for you yeah
you are you do sound different who are
you aah get away get away don't whatever
you do don't check under the stairs no
one checks under the stairs yeah
oh what's that buddy oh yeah bye-bye no
one likes you anyway
you big loser big loser
big fat loser actually you're quite
skinny excellent big skinny loser I'm
out of here
I'm out of here get out of mouth climb
up the stairs God guy you are bad
stair walking this all right where am I
going what am i doing what's going on na
dhanam a wooden handle of sorts yay ok I
know where this good Oh cuz I'm so smart
all right is that guy gone better be he
doesn't want mess with this Oh fists of
fury right here ready to tear you up son
get out of here okay Kurt chunk oh yeah
open up can I close it awesome super
smart I said super smart go down not up
okay there we go good job anyway stupid
handle you always good for this oh it
looks right oh my god well I beat it's
an ominous color but at least it's
well-lit get me out of here the shrine
okay huh familiar this looks like the UM
the the chancel from of amnesia probably
borrowed a lot what's this a bowl here
they pour my potion in here yep that
makes sense oh hello dang oh oh you're
still naked I'll get out of here
Alexander oh I killed you so hardcore
along with myself why am i if I'm Daniel
why are you still alive
Oh get out of here oh you're so naked Oh
return wait a minute oh I'm dead
oh I get it I'm dead maybe yes I am
oh-ho ten points to Gryffindor uh yep
I'm dead I know I'm dead because I died
I saw myself die oh you guys saw me die
uh-huh okay that makes sense and if you
didn't decide to pick up any clothes for
your soul all the way yeah okay
happy up yep this makes sense if you can
overcome such memory loss I've as one
who could I died prematurely in my first
life you were like 900 years old I wish
so much to return to my world
ah I ended up in your world and then I
discovered the power of the orbs and
just as I thought about the return home
you interfered by shoving the head of
another old guy in there you killed me
and I've I said please well you seemed
well founder of a heal yourself
I sound like Count Chocula now what is
the last thing that you remember being
attacked by van of my former servant
then my revenge is almost complete you
will so kind to open the portal for me
Daniel now I don't have to go through
the trouble of doing it myself
Oh Oh Asajj I will not kill you verily
no directly oh I'm so gonna kill you
again I am sure whatever creatures lurk
in this van would be more than happy to
take care of it for me now I return home
and there is nothing you can do to stop
me oh yeah good luck in whatever realm
you end up in next good riddance Daniel
Oh
bring it on Oh bring it on I have to
follow him let me follow him how do I
follow him yeah I mean I mean ah damn it
[ __ ] okay I guess that might have been
oh yeah yeah here we go oh I'm coming
for you [ __ ] bring it on Oh markiplier
gonna kick your ass Daniel is not doing
[ __ ] I'm doing it ah what the hell
oh okay I still made it
I'll give up it all get ready oh can of
whoop-ass on you
oh hello ladies
Oh why are you oh okay they just turned
away they're shy cuz of my handsomeness
all right get here I'll bring it on oh
my whip yo ass from here till Wednesday
oh wow this is okay um world's do exist
must don't worry oh this is out Ted okay
Helen what a stupid name but she's fat
ugly actually Helens a great uh I
apologize if any of your named Helen I
love the name Helen all right ha I get
it I get it out of here get get out of
here
get get I'm out of here oh you can't
touch this you don't know where I'm am
do you
all this is a bad get out of here mm
it's whale call man or moose man
constipated moose oh oh there were like
nine doors you don't even know which one
I'm in
[Music]
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
just get out of here move on buddy you
got no chance you got no chance
alright might as well stand in the light
I suppose or lose sanity is he going
away
is he gone the music would say otherwise
we don't hear him anymore hello hello
hello yeah you gone get out of here
buddy I'm not your friend buddy I'm not
talking ah he's still there why is he
still there why is he still there get
out of here buddy
I'm not your buddy pal get out of here
okay
Peggy's dagger tinderbox key Oh lots of
stuff in this room the four yay key this
is smash I'll fry it dumb idea don't
smash object there don't I
trick chest try to fake me out all right
um didn't the boxes not Simone what was
that
Oh God locks breaking anything under
here above here as I saw stacked over no
reason no reason at all did he go away
now you gone do I need oil yes I do I'll
finally have plenty of oil hello anybody
what's this for yeah I don't want to go
there just yet you can see what's going
on over here hey y'all ooh chests
lots of chests I like it this gimmick
nothing didn't the boxes give it nothing
a note cannot remember what day it is
walking dead masters a turn okay ah oh
good out of here someone was upset at
those beds Oh open up
I gotcha man did not like that bed right
anyway moving on
get open actually I have to pause it
here thank you guys so much for watching
and I will see you in the next part bye
bye